but stealing jokes
in comedy that's like the ultimate what
is it with comedy
and the amount of controversy sometimes
you see
when it comes down to somebody using
somebody else's jokes where where is the
you know crossing the line to say listen
man you took my joke that's mine that's
not cool
you see you know the whole i've had
carlos mancia on before you've seen the
carlos mission
broken back and forth from god knows how
many years ago was why
is that so serious in the comedy
industry well you know
doing the technique for a shot is
different right because there's only
certain ways you can shoot i mean you
know you're not going to have
uh you know kevin durant jump in this
jump in the air to do a jump shot and
spread his legs wide and
you know make a funny face and throw it
up and it goes in there's a technique to
it right
so that's the technique similarly with
stand up there's techniques to
certain things again like i said there's
techniques to
being present on stage if you look at a
bunch of comics you'll see the ones who
are high energy have kind of a similar
way of presenting themselves but the
jokes themselves
that stealing that the analogy would be
let's say in basketball
it wouldn't be so much oh you are doing
the same move that i'm doing
but it's almost like saying you
you are you know you've been watching my
press conference and saying the same
things i
say uh or or even going one step further
it's almost it's i would almost say it's
like you took my trophy
because because our jokes are are what
make us
that's our story i spent blood sweat and
tears
to write my act my act is my act
now if you go especially this happens
unfortunately where a bigger act will go
and see
an unknown act and say oh i like that
and then they'll go do that on tv and
now they've put their stamp on it yeah
and this poor kid who's been working you
know
working as the as the doorman at the
club and getting three minutes
of stage time once a week he just had
his whole
act that it took him a year to build
stolen from somebody and that person is
doing it on tv
that is just a total no-no and in
stand-up
you know it's closer to what what they
do with music when
when a lot of musicians go oh you took
that riff that i did and you put it in
your song and now you're making millions
of dollars
uh-uh ain't gonna go um you know i
looked up
you know the in michael jackson mama
saying mama
i looked it up and that was an african
singer who had a song that said mama
it was mama that's the whole thing
and it's funny because supposedly
michael was doing the song
and at some point he started riffing
because the song has nothing to do with
mama
he just started to say mama say the song
takes off
this guy shows up and goes whoa that's
my song you can't just do my song in
your song
so that's the thing and and in comedy
listen the the one good thing because i
matter of fact early on when i first got
into comedy i was talking to somebody i
said
isn't there a way for us to copyright
our jokes so that nobody else can take
them and unfortunately
there is no you know government
entity where you could say oh here's my
copy written joke you know you can do
that with your scripts you can go to
writer's guild of america
not comedy comedy you can't but the best
the best thing you can do is get it out
on a special
and once it's out on a special and it's
there and if somebody comes and says
oh you took that joke from so so you're
gonna know i did that joke in 2008
here's the proof and that's all we can
do so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]